[Applause]
of us the invitation to impose peace on the lord
planned Ukrainian people
who have been suffering from the horror of war for six months now
but have immediately
that concrete steps are not pending to
put an end to the war and avert
the risk of a nuclear disaster in
flavors
lead us to which prisoners
especially those who are in
fragile conditions and I ask
the responsible authorities to work towards
their release
and I am thinking of the children
so many dead
then
so many refugees so there are so many
injured
so many Ukrainian children and Russian children
who have
become orphans from not  it was a nationality
they lost their father and mother they
are red they are grown up
I think it
has so much cruelty
to many innocent people who are paying the
madness the madness
the madness of all sides because
war is madness and no one who in
war can say no I am not  crazy the
madness of war
I think
now poor girl
blown up by a bomb that was
under the seat
of the car at mos  ca
innocents pay for the war the innocents
let's think of this reality and let's say
another war is madness and those
who earn with war and with the
trade in arms
are criminals
who kill humanity